what age would you make social media
like legal for
kids um never I
feel allow to join until I was like 13
yeah same with my and so so the same
idea with getting my ears pierced it was
like get social media and get your ears
PS 201 year 13 that's cute do you know
in the history of man we are the only
and first multi-generation that have
ever been through anything like this
everything else has been tested in some
weird cyclical way but one day we'll
look back and be like we were the people
that helped put an age to this figure it
out all of it anyway those are my that's
my inner
voice um okay last confession I was
engaged in preschool oh my God that's
the cutest thing ever
[Music]
a all right is everyone ready all right
reveal
why are you coming for
me well we have three winners because it
is
Chris not the AC she she's a this just
gas like she didn't look over at my
board and copy my answer I was already
thinking Chris I just like wanted to
confirm confirm with okay who were you
engaged to uh her name was Sarah and I
have no idea where she is in this world
and um lost love it's not like I engaged
like I bed um I think I was told that we
were
engaged by and um we never broke up we
just like oh so you're still engaged
technically I guess
so that is so
[Music]
sweet